you know like don't mess with the girl
they'll find out don't mess with the go
especially this one hi i'm nicola peltz
hi i'm brooklyn beckham and this is the
gq couple's quiz all right i was really
old
are you ready 100
okay name all of my siblings oldest
youngest but you have two sets of twins
so you want me to say the oldest of
those two years as well oh gosh the
bonus matt
will
brittany brad diesel
zach greg
yeah okay there's so many siblings the
twins
okay what music videos have i been in
miley cyrus
yeah
zayn yes bonus can you give me the names
of the songs i don't know i have no idea
okay i'll give you a hint the first the
miley cyrus is has your favorite number
in it it's a song called number seven no
but seven
things yeah about me seven things really
yes and then the other one you know
you're not going to get it no no what is
it okay it's you it's you okay okay okay
you did pretty good what was my first
acting role
oh it was a christmas movie it's with
the guy from matilda yeah
i know ah what's it called it's not
jingle the way
i forgot what is it
deck deck the halls
i say he gets half a point because he
knows he knows it was a christmas movie
what would my job be if i weren't
entertainment detective oh
100 percent detective that was so fast
no okay wait bonus what kind of
detective homicide homicide
i think
silence is lambs and all like that's so
fascinating she loves to snoop around
okay what sport did i play growing up i
don't know this one
oh boy
and
be specific what is my night routine so
she puts on this little robe and then
she puts her hair up on one of these
like stretchy black bandanas thing so
her hair's outside of her face
she
washes her face with this like foamy
like cleanse thing and then she puts on
all her creams which there's a few of
them
as she's walking to the bed she turns on
the heat which is probably the only
thing that we fight about
um and then she gets him she goes by her
cupboard and she puts on these really
fluffy really ridiculously warm
she puts on my really baggy tracksuit
bottoms but she rolls them
and then she puts on one of my t-shirts
because she likes the smell of my
aftershave
and then she gets in bed and then she
asks me to put
one of these big fluffy white blankets
in the dryer so it's warm
and then i tuck her in
and then i put the other blanket on her
and that's and then okay well
you killed that yeah that was a lot of
points you did really well
what is my astrological sign
[Music]
i remember it
it's similar to pop
capricorn popcorn capricorn that's kind
of january 9th is her birthday
yes
okay
describe my ideal wedding
probably
our two families very small very
petite you know very
lovely like
colors like light your favorite colors
light pink light blue
you know creams
that's
kind of
like that i don't really you know i
don't know okay but
our wedding's gonna be lovely you did
have good
what food do i hate
you hate uni
i love uni we love sushi that's the one
food she doesn't like
okay
what do i love about you
everything
very kind to you uh
i cook you food whenever you want i make
the best tea
because i'm english i would say i'm a
gentleman right i hold the door open
okay you're enough you're done okay
what are three things i would change
about you um i
i love ice i chew ice all the time
you hate when i i have to sleep in the
cold
so as soon as she falls asleep literally
we have a room we have a rule where
she's allowed to have it as hot as she
wants before we go to bed and then as
soon as she falls asleep i can make it
as cold as i want yeah i feel like
there's one more thing oh i know
you do
[ __ ]
oh i don't know what is it
you write your nails oh yes
i bite my nails
cause i get anxious
okay how do you know when i'm mad at you
she doesn't speak to me
ever
you know in your car and like your mom
and dad are mad at you and you just have
to stay outside the window
it's like that she just does not speak
to me
silent treatment
girls the worst
okay
what's my cell phone number you're not
gonna get this one do you know what i
just memorized my own number yeah but
shouldn't you have like a in case of
emergency contact that you should
memorize no
okay
do you know any of my digits
in my phone it's plus one
after that i don't know great
what's my number plus four or four
no exactly plus four four plus one okay
okay
what's my nickname for you either babe
or baby i get upset sometimes when you
call me brooklyn because i'm like oh
what have i done
oh gosh okay
who is my celebrity crush he's english
christian bale
a little bit jealous to be honest
talented man where did we have our first
kiss we had our first kiss at
a halloween party it was like one of the
first nights we started hanging out yeah
it was by the bar i was buying like four
beers
someone said like kiss me so she kissed
me on the cheek i was like what
and i really liked her so i just grabbed
her face and kissed her so i made the
first move
i'm killing this by the way i only got
like too long what is my starbucks order
uh-huh it's a really annoying
word
what
i don't know the first bit of it there's
two truvia on the side yeah
it's a bit of oat milk
or oatmeal
almond milk fake news yes almond milk
wrong milk
you've seen those videos where it's like
girls who order starbucks and they're
like and the orders like so long that is
what is it are you giving up yeah
sugar-free dolce de leche
see what i mean dolce de leche no we're
too chewy i got the two truvia oh you
get none how long does it take me to get
ready
sometimes it's half an hour
if i get really lucky then it's 20
minutes
if we're going somewhere very special
then it's around an hour
and then if we learn something really
really really special it takes a bit
longer
but she's pretty quick love you love you
oh boy this one's spicy
what was my first impression of you
she did not like me at first
at all we've actually known each other
five years
and
we knew of each other like we ran into
each other multiple times and i was
actually friends with two of her
brothers diesel and brad
and she did not like me
and then
when we started hanging out which was
about three halloweens ago which is
where we had our first kiss i you know
we started hanging out every night and
we drove around for like seven eight in
the morning do you remember
we drove around all
no we didn't we all we did was drive
around la and you know i i showed her
that i could be that i am a gentleman
and
you know she fell in love with me
yeah yeah and that's it you did really
well you got this many points
good luck
why is my name brooklyn because when
your mom found out she was pregnant she
was on tour of the spice girls
all right
list the teams my dad has played for
are you kidding me there's seven you
have to name
three
manchester united
that is one that's all i know remember
you thought it was pronounced
oh yeah real madrid i thought it was
real interesting
there's two more that i know you can get
why did i move out to la
oh la galaxy yes
and where did i have my first pasta
making lesson italy
madrid
mexico no it has an m though oh milan ac
milan
nice there was a lot on here i didn't
even know he played for one of those
i'll give you four points oh i'll give
you four points yeah maybe four points
pretty good
what was my first job i worked in a cafe
what kind of cafe coffee cafe
yes and i was absolutely horrendous at
it what tattoos do i have
all of them yep oh my gosh you have an
eagle the number seven
lover you have a love note to me
you have n my mom's rosary you have
a girl which is questionable tattoo for
me it's not based on anyone
it was an old-school pinup it's still
questionable
and then he has the sword that his
parents
used to cut their wedding cake with
roses around it another like love letter
to me with my birthday and my name a mom
and dad tattoo mama's boy you have
beckham
you have angels and clouds what do i
have here i promise you love me
then you have
my eyes
and the first love like letter i wrote
you and then i have one more on my neck
oh you have a ship on one of your arms
you have 23
june 23rd because when we got engaged
okay but this can go on and on how many
tattoos do i have 80 some
83
yeah wow
not bad i did not know you're gonna get
that i killed that i feel like i won
that does not mean eighty-three points
okay i'll give you seven points that you
named how many i have and then i'll give
you a half a point for every tattoo that
you got for me
who are my godparents
dave gardner
and elton john
two points for that it's not bad who is
my favorite sibling
oh
i don't know about your favorite but i
would say
your closest um in personality wise to
crews like most similar to cruz i don't
have a favorite i love all three of them
i'm really close with all of them but me
and cruz are a lot more similar harper
is an angel they're all is an angel
perfect you get a good point for that
you get a good point for that i'll give
you that what is my
favorite movie of all time the holiday
he wants to watch it all year round like
summer time
a good
movie i love it because one of the
ladies in the movie has the cutest
little house in england
it kind of looks like my mum and dad's
house in the countryside and then
there's like an la girl who is into
movies and she's a producer or something
like that
and
it's just i don't know
england and la kind of reminds me of us
so
yeah i'll give you a good point that's
good what's my hidden talent oh he can
do like
that
yeah
no that was that's my only hidden talent
it's my party trick
good point for that well done thank you
describe my perfect meal but you have
the name on the i'm adding this what on
my favorite dish i'm pretty sure you
know my favorite dish because i talk
about it all the time fingers and mash
but there's three things on so there's
sausage sausage and mashed potatoes and
onions yes
yes i'll give you three points for that
well done my favorite i love it three
points guys i've killed this what's the
best way to piss me off
don't say i love you back in five
seconds yes
there's one that i was not thinking of
john takes you back right away no but
that does annoy me so
half a point oh chewing with your mouth
my mouth oh my gosh i'll give you two
points
she does do it you know when she's
trying to piss me off she does do it on
purpose but she doesn't she doesn't do
it that much you've got two points for
that what's the best way to make me
laugh i do laugh quite a lot and i look
at you in a serious way you laugh when i
ask you a serious question
she does this thing where i get annoyed
and then she's like don't laugh don't
laugh and then it makes me giggle so
that was a good point well done okay i
think you know this what phrase do i
overuse oh he says the word obviously a
lot
like obviously but it's not obvious
you know when some people be when
they're talking they're like um
i change that and i'd say obviously
that was a point well done what's your
biggest pet peeve of mine and there's
there's three
chewing ice
we all know
oh he does this really weird thing where
he washes his hands with like a face and
then he dries with a face towel but then
the face towel i'll find in like really
weird places he like will leave in the
bedroom something you find in the living
room like the face out travels
everywhere i like to hold a face towel
until i don't and then i leave it really
random places yes i'll give you two
points for that
who is the messier person you or me you
by the way
it goes both ways because there is no
way in
oh my god we have his and her
sinks but she leaves
all of her makeup around
all the sinks and i don't i don't find
that clean
i find that a bit messy it's just during
the process but no it's not so it kind
of goes both ways so i'll give you a
half a point for that you're right you
are a bit of a messy person as well
disagree who hogs the bed sheets
me yeah you're right by that one what's
my nickname for you a baby
yeah we call each other the same thing
or misses yeah cool of my misses like
not to me but if he's talking about me
when i try to annoy him
so annoying when i when i tried to annoy
her call my mom i call her my bird which
is like an english thing that's such a
weird phrase i don't understand it it
sounds like it's an english thing like
oh like that's my bird over there
oh no i don't like it's like saying like
oh that's my man
my mia you get a point i'll give you
that
okay this is easy what show do we bind
watch oh gilmore girls the best show in
the world we love it if you're not um
i'm not gonna sing it but i know the
intro from start to finish he's team
jess
yeah i feel bad for dean but
i am team jess dean
what's my guilty pleasure well i don't
think it's that guilty but i take it
more girls mm-hmm no i'm so open about
my camera goes i would say your little
boxy bring everywhere and you play
fortnite but you have it in a suitcase
so i have this playstation it's so cool
it's like a little suitcase but it opens
up and it's like a screen and it fits
your ps5 and two controllers you can
plug it in anywhere it's the coolest
thing like that so he brings it
something from our bedroom to the living
room that's so cool that's
my favorite thing i own that's a good
question oh that's good answer what is
my biggest fear well i know a funny one
he hates square plates and bigfoot oh my
gosh not scared of them but they just
they more like just piss me off there's
one animal that i just don't like oh i
don't know that
snakes i love snakes i don't know what
animal you don't like
you don't what was this was this a hint
it's that yeah it's that big a rat not a
mine nuts a hamster no not scared of a
hamster an armadillo can fit in a what
no an armadillo i don't know you went
like this i know that they're kind of
big right i hate cockroaches oh what the
cockroach is not this big summer this
big yes no yes i hope someone should
send you a video of a cockroach that
they're like this neko they come in all
different sizes
some of them are massive i disagree
all right okay i don't get that one i
said armadillo
what's the most british thing about me
okay when he gets drunk he does this
like fake british accent and he turns it
up like a million degrees i grew up up
north in manchester and i used to have a
really strong accent was like oh yeah
dad like that it was it was my life
it was more he goes out that's more like
that's more of like a scouser accent but
like i really like sound like this like
honestly like i can't even like do that
i mean like man mandan wants to just go
down to the pub and you know have a nice
little pint nice beer it only comes on
when i drink yeah so when i get really
drunk it just automatically comes out
yeah that is pretty british
oh my god no you have to i can't my
brain is telling me not to do this i
want to go and look at my bird go on i
wanna go look at my bird
i hate you
i wrote two bonus questions okay and i'm
pretty sure you know both
but we'll see what is my favorite drink
and step by step how do i make it a gin
and tonic what kind of gym monkey 47
tonic water ice
rosemary yeah cucumber
yep two more things raspberries nope
strawberries no sometimes it grows in
the garden
mint yes
there's one more thing to make it acidic
mine yes
not bad i'll give you like i'll give you
two i'll give you two points for that
what is my favorite book the giving tree
well done that was good you got this
many points well done thank you thank
you so much for watching i personally
think i won but thank you guys for
watching let's go